rl
[Música]
e aí a segunda turma vocês a comédia
quero dizer a você que tá muito difícil
a esse vídeo que eu chamei um pedreiro
pacote de um buraco está ficando a
parede do meu quarto e eu disse que se
ele chegar tão cedo aqui em casa sabe aí
eu saí para comprar pão quando eu voltei
para tratar da nokia no aparelho e falei
cara mais velho
cheguei tão cedo em minha casa que não
construirão enfim se eu estava
conversando com meus amigos e tal e aí
começamos o negócio escola estava quase
tudo é estudado em escola particular e
eu acho que eu sou muito meu amigo não
estudou em escola particular sempre
estudou em escola pública e escola
pública até as coisas são muito
engraçado eu achei muito legal acho que
a escola porque a gente interage muito
com as pessoas naquela coisa assim muito
certinha só você interage com o vigia da
escola sem grade com 11 jogadoras
interagir com o professor sims e
interage com a galera da loucas mano
brow quebrada logo aí você chega na sua
escola estava vigiando a cadeirinha
desde encostado na parede faz bom dia
bom dia ae decano da pura
aí acontece alguma coisa na escola
alguém time leva kelly tal se rala quem
chega lá com dipirona o vigia aí às
vezes professor falta né e tal até a
todo mundo já grita acham que não vai
ter aula passa um pouco tempo vi gente
passar da hora do recreio da hora do
lanche para chantagear merendeira
revelador para deixar a menina quem está
entregando mg mas é assim mesmo essas
coisas de escola pública tem muito corte
de gastos com têxteis corte de gasto bem
aí já é uma pessoa faz um trabalho em um
milhão ou por derrota por um placar
muito estranho é a questão do legislador
é o que eu não sei se estão ligados mas
a escola pública não dá pra colocar ar
condicionado primeiro porque a janela
não só o vento ou são janela na madeira
meu velho meu filme é isso pelo pior é
que o cara que só você estava bom agora
na época que desde a primeira cei porta
da sala que ele vai ter quatro senadores
assim em é e então você estuda em escola
pública sua missão na sala de aula é
sentar na cadeira mais distante daquele
momento a dor que eu junto a vocês que
eu passei na minha primeira cena até o
3º ano só é um complemento à lei falando
assim meu deus é esse meu lado vai
matando agora muita merda está que eu
criava uma expectativa de um dia cair na
cabeça lhe nada a chance de ver se até
uma medida educativa né meninas cala a
boca cala a boca a boca não vai acabar
na al 101 sul do estado
agora eu não vou mostrar não foi tão
tabu na cala a boca vai importar pois
fiquei e resolver o problema ninguém
mais faz barulho só vem a dor faz
barulho caso não sei porque demora tanto
tempo para fazer a manutenção daqueles
ventilador escola pública mas enfim
estamos vez que a minha escola tinha o
que tava me arriscar de cair na estrada
com um mercado mais recente é agora de
1992 aos cortes de gás e sarney pode
gastar pouco aproveitado no e escola
pública também no tempo de estudar
tinha muita briga o menino brincava de
mais uma vez não se gostava do ágata e
talves sabia que o colega se eu estava
em um andar tinha pra ela
meu amigo era brilho às vezes acontecer
não ter brigado uma vez de parar na
diretoria de gala diretoria ao atacado
levando diretor lá com ele virava que
estava lá
o vigia estava em uma cirurgia faz tudo
vai melhor que qualquer casal no
banheiro é você vai no banheiro e me já
e tal banho refere que só por mais que
os próprios gregos nemoto nasceram
guilherme janela de bona semana amy já
etapa o centro seja forte e planejar bem
lá na parede vou te comer brick road
bric bem rápido e bpre elbrick é seus
pixels treino não chega cabelo lá pelo
seu ex escala desse pequeno assisti a um
pornô da grécia vem desde um pequeno
pedro não consegue se concentrar e fazer
nada conhecer se você sentar só com até
1 gol só botão permite ao paciente e
assim o joão é [ __ ] ligue pra mim novos
eu que olha que buscar favor coloque o
nome do carro e bota o telefone do carro
do cabo ligar pra ele ser enviado de
deus do céu
está na brincadeira escreveu assim no na
caixa d'água da privada assim eu calei
aqui em outro dia quando eu voltei tinha
se eu também vou riscar o perdedor meio
e também o da menina é que a obra melhor
pra mim que eu acho que a escola não
dizer que também é que a minha escola dá
um forte incentivo no sistema
educacional porque de 300 alunos 255
estão ali por conta da marina eu era um
deles é biscoito cream cracker com
goiabada no meio caso você não tem noção
tanto isso é bom porque queria agradecer
à pessoa que criou o cardápio da merenda
escolar porque é uma coisa assim genial
que toda criança precisa biscoito água e
sal goiabada
além de começar o que é um estado que é
feito um com um povo que nem é natal ele
é um negócio histórico água quente tem
sempre uma desgraça livro é conectar um
outro dia é com os cursos com o ovo que
que se você for premiado se você tiver
um dia ele só se encontrou dentro
criticou o meu amigo se você está na
frente do vasco você pega um curso que
realmente verdade do fundo do coração de
ver com um ovo dentro você pode levantar
pra evitar é o vulgar mas a merenda até
que é bom né o biscoito é mafioso e um
dos melhores que existe muito obrigada a
quem inventou isso naqueles coisa má
posição tão ruim pra fazer um biscoito
água e sal ser de água e sal eu acho que
não saio e volto já que ele escuta só
agora escolhia às vezes quando eu achar
muito ruim a merenda é eu chorava muito
e meu pai me dá uns 50 12 reais para
poder lançar agora no chão que já vem
desde parece que já há muita gente estão
sensor quando você compra um lanche vai
perceber que ele é automaticamente acha
gente se bem que eu também quando meus
amigos compraram ocorrido mesmo atrás
bastava massa por exemplo que 17 amigo
cada me comprou o coxinha eu comi um
pedaço de cada um pronto falava coxinha
sua filha da minha barriga e já mas é
assim sempre foi assim sempre vai ser
feito pode comprar o lanche que podem
pôr um pé no eles vão te achar lá todos
amigos te achar lá e vou cometer erros
mas é assim enganar e também não importa
o colégio vocês tudo você tem os bons
amigos e tem umas boas
ué eu sempre estudei a minha vida
inteira inteira escola porque isso não
me faz diferente quem estuda numa escola
particular e talvez que o oscar da
desgraça velho uma desgraça não importa
o que importa o lugar no contexto
importa interesse de quem tá funcionando
e é aquela coisa se você gosta de se
vestir realmente aquele joinha eu quero
que você comente aqui embaixo qual é a
coisa mais engraçada que aconteceu
enquanto você estuda se a escola pública
é particular tanto faz não falei eu
sinto investir no canal sempre culpando
coisa nova para poder melhorar mais
ainda existe ea lógica ano e agora é que
está me ajudando recentemente faltar
gente recentemente a gente fez dele um
projeto aí e o dinheiro que eu ganhei em
um certo tipo de venda aí eu vou doar
para afinar sua pipa que ajuda animais
eo resto vou sempre investir no canal
comprando microfone pouca coisa sei se
vocês sabem mas aqui não tem microfone
câmera foi na câmara de mauá
se eu ficar pra cá já está a ficar um
pouco ruim e um link da canon é o
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo você
quiser visitar lá ver os produtos tal
você comprando alguma coisa você já vai
estar me ajudando então é isso aí vocês
e me ajudam se não está inscrito no
canal se inscrevem tiver mais vídeos e
vai saber e é nóis redes sociais também
na descrição do vídeo falou galera